Mark: Alright, cool cool, make it a harder difficulty. Make it harder. Hang on, I gotta go get a drink.
Bob: Ohhh my god.
(Mark: A MINI FRIDGE)
(Mark: I AM A MAN)
(Mark: WITH A MINI FRIDGE)
(Mark: Yeahhhh)
(Mark: YEAHHHH)
(Mark: OH! What's this?)
(Mark: From my mini fridge?)
Wade: Oh Man... private co-op
Bob: Wade, now you left us.
Wade: *Gibberish*
Mark: Guys, guess how far I went to get my... my drink
Wade: How far?
Bob: Three f-...  three feet?
Mark: I went to my mini fridge
Bob: Oh Shit, is it in your office?
*Mouth full* MMHMM
Bob: Now Wade's the only loser who doesn't have a mini fridge in his office
Bob: Wade, you grubby bi- you son of a-
*Mark laughs*
Bob: You piece of shit!
Bob: Keanu, You selfish dickhole!
Mark: Yeah wha- Come on! Wade!
Wade: Well you know maybe...
Wade: If you wouldn't have killed my dog I wouldn't have to worry
Bob: I should smack your fucking face off
Mark: I can't believe you just take it without even considering our feelings.
Wade: Oh, well I did and it was easy
Mark: Well I'll- I'll dj- I'll take this then.
Bob: I'm going off on my own, apparently
Bob: See you, bitches
Mark: Yeah! Screw you!
Wade: Alright, see you later
Mark: All right, bye! Catch you around the bend!
Mark: Alright...
Mark: Look, I don't care about your sexual fetishes over there...
Wade: Alright, I'm gonna cut through the claw water corner death room
Mark: Yeah, you would, you pervert! You sexual deviant!
*Intesnse sci-fi music*
Wade: Okay, so far so good, ALRIGHT look at this-
Bob: Oh nohoho....
Bob: Oh, goodbye boot. I lost my boot.
Wade: I need to check that way...
Mark: What is that?
Bob: What? What is- what? wait! Hang on! Wait for me!
Wade: *Un-deciphered* Check the way out
Mark: Guys I got something
Bob: Where are you?
Mark: What does this do?
Mark: What is this?
Wade: That's the way down.
Bob: Oh yeahh...
Mark: OOH!
Wade: *Evil Laugh*
Mark: I Did NOT go down!
Bob: Oh,I hit the ceiling.
Wade: HEy Bob! right here, look, for you
Bob: A Shoe!!
See, I'm not so greedy as Keanu now. Am I?
B: you're still a ho-
M: Wooaahhhh
All: *noises of shock*
B: Look at that thing! Thats fucking cool
Guys I'm gonna go I'm gonna face the dragon I can tell this is my challenge. This is this room. This is my destiny
There's alligators
M: WoahhahhOoh
I'm okay Oh jump. Yes I'm the best
Yeah, I'm good. Dude. I'm good. Yeah, you eat whatever you're eating. Okay
W: Imma go this way cus
it's not that way
M: dude I nailed it
B: That's kinda cool man- that's kinda cool.. WEEeeee
B: Mark Keep the door open!
M: I don't how do I do that? Oh
*Bob yelling at mark* M: Oh God! Im opening it! Hang on- han- Im Opening it
*Bob: MARRKK* M: ITS OPENINGGG
B: OH  hey hows it going
Mark: Hi hey how ya doing. Bob: I only have one bandage. Mark: oh you want it you want it you want it
Here take it Bob: Noo- no
No. Oh, how the fuck did you even do that? How do you drop them?
Mark: I just dragged it to the on the floor option
*wade mumbles* Bob: Oh we have inventory - why do we have inventory?
Wade: THERES A BALLOON
Bob: If There's only one item. Oh Guys there's a  present! (Mark: present, present) Guys the present is definitely good
Wooahhh Bob: Oh wait i forgot about that
Bob: Ummm umm ummmm. Wade: Woahh
wade: I'm Being blown everywhere! Mark: dude, tell me about it.
Bob: All right I have a zappy room over here. Oh, holy shit
Wade: Hooooollly shit
Mark: HEy whats going on guys! Hey wassup
Bob and wade: *greetings* how ya doing
Mark: what're you talking about? Bob: we found a fun room and Wade was a bitch and didn't wanna do it
Mark: that seems like wade
wade: This looks like a Mark kind of room. Mark: You Righ. you  Right,  you right. You're right. You're right
Bob: Man, no fucks given, huh?
Mark: Yeah, that's how I rollll
Bob: Huh- ooohh oOOOooooOHh
Wade: So the room- *Bob: ow oww owowowow* -death room
Bob: yeah this one's chill. M: is it. Bob: Yeah. I mean I'm in a good place except for the all the damage I took. M: Okay cool
Bob: That was my own fault as much as anything else. M: Ooo chains. Bob: Where did Wade go?
W: I'm right across the way if you guys open the door over there. Hey, so I saw you
*All shouting heys*
Bob: Kianu wassup bro. W: -Friends over there !Oh
W: Oh btw you know how we point when you left click?
Yeah
If one of us goes in one of these death rooms, and you guys are around to watch it
If you left click you'll salute us. B & M: Oh
W: If we die. M: I don't believe you you gotta prove that. Dude we are killing it
W: Umm this room is not- M: I feel like all of this is excessively necessary
M: EEhhhh
Bob: *repeating* Im gonna open this one *x4*
W: Only that corners bad, only that corners bad
M: ohGOD Oh God oh god OOoohh *mark and Bob exclaiming*
Bob: Mark! Mark safe, safety. I found safety
M: what? Did you?
Wade: Ow
W: Oh God. M: what do you mean safe? AHHH my ankles! It wasn't safe! Bob: no this room is safe
M: whatt roooom? Bob: uuuhh this room is safe!
M: Look I am trying to find (Bob: MArk) all the rooms that we need to go
I'm trying to find the exit you're trying to find oh
*burp* something!
Bob: thIS ROom!
W: Im at the exit!! Bob: Ahh shit
Bob: Where are you? W: I'm south of one of you? Bob: oh, I'm right here
Bob: Exittttt!!!
Bob: HEyy Buddy! Mark: hey wait for me wait guys wait for me
Bob: SEE mark! See mark!
M: LADA DEE DA DEE LA DA DEE DA DEYYYYY
Bob: see, you see?
W: just Gonna bandage up real quick (Bob:Skuwoosh) M: bandages are for pussies.
Well, that's why I don't have any you do
W: *Ahem* M: Alright
*mumbling* Bob: Good joke bud
M: *under breath* thats what Kianu Reeves does say
W: OOooooh
Bob: Im gonna check this guy out
W: Yeah im gonan go with Bob
M: Im gonna go this way- you idiots
Bob: It's not safe. its not safeee! M: guys, you guys are missing out on the ultimate safe route. I'm
Destroying this with my safety.
W: this does look pretty safe. Bob: Oh wait did you go this way?
M: Dude it's sh- I been three in a row safe perfectly safe. Bob: Ah, no wait, let me in M: I am the goddamn master. No
Danger. W:  I'm gonna veer off this path.
M: DOnt
M: Ah wait, yes, do, do - there's do *Bob  laughing* I feel like I feel like
*bob mimicking* dO Do do that
W: Alright alright
M: Easy easy easy
M: this is so easy
W: Im guessing that ones a bad- Bob: Merk, mark youre a fucking wiz- where'd your boot go? okay
M: I am the fucking greatest
B: Youre a fucking wizard bro
M: you guys, stick to me, s-Oohkay
Bob: Yeah go! Go BRo go!
*Mark laughing* Bob: CHarge!
Yeah, I know right here yeah, come on yeah see no me first me first me first me first! Bob: holy fuck
*gibberish* bob: -acutally a fuckin wizard over here
M: Ahh- It aint no problem, whatever I'm blind. I don't need to see. Bob: Don't stop Oh No
(Bob: Mark!) M: Ahh not that WAY NOT THAT WAY
Bob: wait wait wait I change my mind!
Bob: I change my mind! I don't trust you as much as I did a moment ago
Bob: Reckless abandon. M: Yeah, I don't think we should have this much reckless abandon Bob
Bob: Reckless abandon. W: That's trap. Oh
Bob: Ohh- I open that one. That's not a good one. I'm gonna go to the mark one
(W: Oh thats a bad - thats a-) M: Okay well we've got a bit of a conundrum
Bob: There was a bandage? wait wait wait. Mark: no, no, there was not a- Bob: oohh that's not a good room
*Wade trying to talk* Bob: Oh no there is a bandage, mark there is a bandage it's totally fine
M: Uh yeah that's okay. I don't even need it
Bob: Why can't I why why hey okay, I got it totally worked out
*Bob and Mark noises*
*Marks continued noises* Bob: Whi- which one- which one are you-
M: OH GOD I ALMOST DIED
(M: DUDE) W: I found- I found it!
M: God why does wait always find it..  oh hi.
Bob: so we need to go through this fucking room, alright
M: Yeah whatever, reckless abandon dude
Bob: whats the one on the other side of this? i don't remember
W: Ahh. M: Ahhh probably fine
w: its fine, nothing much
*All three making shocked monkey noises*
Bob: I DONT REMEMBER
x2
x3
x4
x5
Bob: AHH
(M: Laughing) Bob: I made it it's fine! Reckless abandon!
W: WEEEEEE
M: Reckless abandon!
Bob: Alright mark... i fuckin- i fucking trust you with my li-OooOOOOUGHH
*Mark laughs*
Bob: I don't trust you with my life, that's not what i was going to say at all
Bob: I trust you with my l-uughh-ifeee
*Mark giggle*
*M and W Mumbles* Bob: Which one do I open? Which one do I open?
M: Uhh Right go right! Bob:  go right I'm going right. I'm doing what you said pappa
Bob: Are you proud of me?
M: NooOOO (Bob: OW FUCK)
M: W-AHHHH I didn't ReAliZe
W: Please please please please
Bob: What is that kerchunking?
I am moving on like a genius
Bob: You're fucking- you're a champ over here
M: Dude I- whaaat the hellll is thaaaaaat?
*Wade whispers ows* Bob: Oh there's snippers!
M: What is thaaaat
Bob: Oh, I'm this kind of dead. You guys want to come watch this? It's pretty fun
*Bob and Wade Bumbling excuses*
Bob: salute you salute me, please please God. W: Okay. I'm trying. Bob: W-Wade you promised me you promised. I promise
W: Okay there we go! I - I did it!
Bob: Oh thank you. Okay. Well. M: all right. I gotta make a risk here
(W: I had to right click to salute you)
Bob: I was too reckles- to reckless-
W: AHHHHHHHHH
M: Wha? ... Bob: Huh?
M: Oh God, all right, I'm out of shoes. Here I go.
Bob: You're totally finee- Ohh nice duck dude. M: Thanks, man. Thank you
Bob: That seems fine. That seems fine. M: That's fine
Bob: That's good. Oh- M:it's fine. It's fine. Fine. Bob: Yeah, just try- just ke-keep going
M: alright.... RECKLESS ABANDON!!
M: Fine, good, totally good
Bob: Mark you're fuckin- you're a wizard
M: AHHHH yeahh, oohh yes, oh yes
M: Oh yess. I feel good about this
Bob: Mark you're so good at video games
M: Welcome back to the world of the living
Bob: Oh hey what's up bro!
M: Hey bro, how ya doing
M: Wade get over here!
Bob: would you.... could you?
W: I'm working my way up. M: Wade, come on! Bob:  would you could you on a plane? Could you would you-
W: You're down! Why are you saying up?
M: No we're up. Bob: we are not down. M: No, we're up a floor. You stupid
W: You guys tricked me. I was heading up and you needed me to go downnn
M:  Okay, who's got shoes? Bob: I got shoes bro. I got you
M: Nice
Bob: Hey a shoe! A shoe! Look Mark a shoe!
M: Ayyyeeeee
Bob: Alright, Mark wizard please
Bob: Woww I feel good about this room
M: It means it's safe right this means it's safe
*All three exclaiming various danger noises*
Bob: Nuhh- Not safe! Not safee, oww fuhh
M: AH Oh OH AUGHHH
M: OHH GODDD
Bob: Mark! M: YEssss? Bob: Is it safe?
*Wade laughing* M: I DONT KNOW MAN
M: I don't know what safe means anymore, Oh God. Oh
Bob: Ohhhhh Boy. W: I don't want to go in, oh fuck that
Bob: Wait! Wait! You were safe you were safe! You wer-
*Mark and Bob yelling*
Bob: Oh Mark what have you lead me into?
M: Oh God!
M: Ohhhh God. Bob: hey bud. I died upon you.
M: I didn't say it was- AHHH OUAAHHH
Bob: Ohohh Man, don't do that.
M: I didn't say it was safe
Bob: You knew I trusted you. M: Well don't that's your mistake.
Bob: Graspers! M: ITS FINE ITS FINE ITS FINE ITS FINE ITS FINE
M: It's fine it's fine
Bob: Okayy well..
M: Wait! How'd you get revived? What?
M: YAAAAAAYYYY
Bob: Dude you're actually a goddamn wizard. M: Yeah. I know right
W: GUYS
M: What? W: hey.. I see you
M: I think that means it can't be a death one cuz it's occupying the centre space. Y'know what I mean
Bob: Oh my god how did you guys get through that shit. What the hell? Why did you let that door closed?
Bob: You did it on purposssseee
M: Noo, noooo *Bob yelling*
M: God ow okay. Bob: *sing song* I am soo fucking deaaaad
M: You're not you're not we believe in you! Bob: I am all the way all kinds of dead
M: We believe in you. *Bob repeating the word door* M: OWWW
*Bob repeating door but faster* Bob: OOHH nOOO it's ev- It's less safe!
M: Yeah I know what we gotta do
*Bob yell*
M: *yelling* THIS WAY THIS WAY THIS WAY
Bob: I have four health!
M: You need bandages? Bob: Ohh fu- I got some bandages don't worry I'm totally fine. Good good
W: Im gonna keep going, keep moving
M: Good work Bob
M: There's a ticking coming from this one.. I don't like ticking
M: Oh that's why it's ticking
Bob: Ohh that's- Oh wait woahh watch out for splooshes
M: I gotta heal more. Bob: Is that the one we're going through? What! No!
Mark: Yes! *Bobs monkey noises*
Bob: I found it! M: OH WHAT ! Bob: Come to me, come to me. come to me!
M: But I got hoit (hurt)
M: Im going Im going Im going Im going
*M and W Ooohhing
W: Last Floor!!
M: Yes, this is it guys, this is the dream
Bob: heh
M: That's it
*Mark and Bob burst out laughing*
W: Alright guys! Uh Oh *Wade and bob yell*
Bob: *like a chicken clucking* Fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck!
*Bob gibberish*
Bob: OH My god mark. what fucking fresh hell this- uaghh ahhaah!
M: Dude I don't knowww
Bob: Hey look a boot everything's turning everything's turning around and bandage this thin- M:  I don't know what this thing is. What is this thing?
M: What is this thing? What is th- AHHH
*Mark garbled yelling*
Bob: What do you mean you don't know what this is?
M: OuuAHHHH
M: Okay please don't nooTTT LIKE THISSSS
*Bob laughing*
Bob: I was standing in the corner right here and your boot was just like
*All three chuckling*
W: I thought you were yelling at Mark, I was like "Silly Mark, didn't see Bob"
Bob: Mark has only gone from danger to danger
No, I did no- OWW
M: Ohh goddd fuck meee it hurts so badd
M: Ohhhh
W: Oh god, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.. Oh it's finee
*Splash noise* M: Hoooooo... Bob: Ohhh
M: That didn't sound good. W: THE EXIT! Im at the exit!!
M: Where? Bob: Oh my god.. Oh nooo
M: Oh god it- im on the complete opposite corner!!
*Bob and Wade laughing*
M: Alright. I see the path. I see the path before me. I see the path, I seeee the path
Bob: Mark you got- you gotta see your path. You gotta be there
M: OHWOAAHHHH
M: IM UP! I see the path!
*Bob laughing*
M: I see the pa-oohhhh.(Bob: Oh my fucking god)  I see the path before me
Bob: Mark, stay focused. (W: Im gonna live!)
M: OHWOAAAHH
Bob: You gotta see the path (M: FIREEE) You gotta see it Mark
*Marks garbled yells*
M: It hurts, I do- Im not pathed, m-my path is done
*Mark death noises*
*Bob and Wade yells* Bob:  oh no. wait. Well wade, I guess you can take the exit
W: I'm dancin'
W: Music's playin'
Bob: Well, it's just silence on my screen an awkward wiggling. W:  Oh, I'm boogie'ing
Bob: That's really like  thoroughly underwhelming
W: Umm I think we go back to main menu now. I can't just restart it this
Bob: This i- this is it? W: Mark your calendars everyone today's the day Wade lives and everyone else doesn't, that never happens.
W: wh- dy- anticlimactic win. Wade won,  stop with the anti-climactic bullshit.
M: It was pretty anti climactic
W: It was very.. climactic
M: I climaxed
W: Don't worry guys I'm turning up the difficulty a little bit. Bob: Okay, good. M: Give us the hardest, what is the hardest, yeah
W: Nightmare seven by seven by seven nightmare (M: cool good love it) that last one was six six six
W: It was Satan, but this is nightmare. This is seven sev- Lord minion 777 right? That's me, Kianu Reeves 777
W: You guys are naked. Now you're not. Bob: Hey look boots.
M: Terms of service! Did you get banned?
W: What? M: Did you get banned?
M: Were we naked?
M: Wow Wow, woowwww
I thought it was just a floor one..
*Mark wheezing*
Bob: I didn't realize it was the- it was the water one
M: Oh God
W: That was the quickest an- Bob: I fucking trusted you mark. M: you shouldn't have why would you do that?
M: It's on nightmare mode! Bob: I I trusted you
M: nightmare modeee!
Bob: I, trusted, you. M: NIGHTMARE!
Bob: Implicitly
Bob: Look at this, you're not even taking the bandages. You're such a badass. You didn't fucking (M: found it.) Give a shit.
M: Hey Bob, Guess who's alive? Bob: Oh, dude suck me out of my hole
Bob: Suck me outt!!
*Mark slurping* (um...) AHhh there you are. Bob: Oh.. thank you
M: You're welcome. Shoe behind you. Bob if you trust me implicitly you'll charge in this next room for me
Bob: I'm doing it fucking push the button. Yeah. M: Okay, let's do it. Yeah
*Mark cheering yeah* *Bob cheering and then realizing*
Bob: Awhh Wait
Bob: Mark I trusted you mark
M: Listen... I... W: Salute, right click salute
Bob: Oh no Mark it's nanobots. M:  Oh No
(W: Salute) M: Oh no, oh that's not good
Bob: Can i just speed this up if I okay- well that's not good
M: That's not good. W: Mark don't forget to right click to salute Bob
M: Oh god no
Bob: You better fucking sing me a song of glory
*Wade singing and mark joining in out of sync* He was our Bob and he wmmnkj DIE
He- Beetles in the ahrh
*Bob trying to explain the rooms around him* M&W: Something in my EYE
*Mark singing* Nanobots through the taint of- bwooahhh
M: I Trust myself implicitly
Bob: No Mark, you have to stay alive. you have to bring me back. (M: I trust myself implicilty!) so I can be the one to trust you, implicitly
M: I trust mysel- OH woaaHhh
M: I trust myself implicilty!
Bob: You just fucking dodged a cannon like the ulti- M: I trust myself implicitly!
*Wade trying to speak* M: I trust my- OH heeeEEYYYY
Bob: Holy Fuck! W: Wow
M: Im the fucking best!
M: I am the best! ... Hi Bob!
Bob: You.. are a fucking hero
M: Naww C'mon
Bob: Ohh aw garsh. M: ah garsh. Wade come on loser. Hurry up
Bob: Mark ya wanna, Same-same strat.
M: Yeah go for it
M: Nice. Nice, killer, hell yeah
Bob: We're back in the groove man M: alright we're in the groove
Bob: You pick the door I charge it. M: Okay
Bob: Wahhahahh... M: Oh hell yeah. Bob: Hey, it worked!
M: This is how I do this is how we do this is how we do. This is how we do
M: Oh, yeah, that looks safe. Alright you good you good.
M: Keep running keep running keep running!
Bob: Pick the next door! M: This one this one!
M: Go Go Go
M: Love it. Love it. Love it. Love it. Love you
Bob: Oh yeah it's safety, everything's fine everything's good
M: See, I know how to pick em
*Bob yells* *Mark OOO's*
Bob: *yelling mark*
M: How do you not get chopped into 15 bajillion pieces
Bob: Mark, you're lagging. M: You're lagging! Bob: You're lagging. You're lagging mark your literally-
M: No, you're you're exploding in place. Bob:  Mark. M: look at you. Bob: Oh boy
Bob: Look at what's- Wahhh
M: I had a bad feeling about that room. Bob: I'm glad that we were lagging so that I couldn't charge it oh my god
M: Wade, where are you? Wade, (W: just checking the corner.) Why aren't you with us? Oh
Bob: I forgot that you're trapped in tha- W: CANNON
*Bob laughing*
Bob: Oh wait I didn't do the strat, I'm sorry mark. M: that's okay. (Bob: I do it for you!!!) Maybe we shouldn't do that strat,  maybe caution
Bob: No I do it for you daddy! Caution is for bitchessss
W: Oh hey guys
Bob: This rooms safe it's cool. W: the corners not good. Don't go that way.
M: What? Why? Bob: what's that Chicka Chicka that's concerning. W:  the corners not the way to go is what I'm trying to tell you
Bob: I know that Chicka Chicka is terrifying. W: That's also not the way to go
M: Why'd you throw your shoe in there? Bob: Hey look we're back where we started
W: I  didn't throw a shoe in there. M: I thought you threw your shoe in there
W: I didn't throw my shoe I was tying my shoe. M: Oh what happened in thereee
W: That's where my shoe went. Bob: oh, no, that's not a good way to die. W: Salute you robot guy
Bob: For my daddyy
Bob: Ohh shizzz
Bob: Yes. Oh, please don't. Oh, it's graspers. Oh Mark pick a door. I'm picking my own door. M: Okay, you pick your own door
Bob: Oh it's lasers. Oh, I'm no- I'm unpicking that door
W: Mark this rooms not safe!
M: What doors not safe? WOw hello
Bob: Ow ow ow ow ow okay
M: uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh uh oh
*All yelling* M: BAD ROOM BAD ROOM NOT THERE NOT THERE NOT THERE
Bob: Mark that's not a good one!
Bob: Mark do one better!
M: Oh big oof! Big- ahh god!
M: Oh so much oofing
*still lots of yelling* M: not the water not the water! AHHHH
Bob: That's not the way mark! ahh
M: Guys.. apparently it's not the way
W: Bob, Bob (Bob: everything's fine) Bob you're the only one alive
Bob: I have 20 health (M: you got this.) I know I know. Oh I have forty health actually so
Bob: Tha- That's right. Im fuckin ready for some of this action *mark chuckle*
Bob: Not that way, nuh uh
Bob: we can dream can't we.. can I?
M: Don't
Bob: All right, I'm gonna check out this room. I guess (M: I don't know why it's raining) is rain bad
M: Maybe it'll put you out or maybe it's acid rain. It's acid rain it's acid rain
Bob: *repreating* Ahh it's bad it's bad it's bad
Bob: I feel not safe. windows 95 protect me! guys, I've got the strats
Bob: Oh! Safety! haha! I'm on the road
I-
Bob: I Think I'm gonna go this way. M: Yeah. Good. Good call good call on that one. Yeah, good call.
B: safety. Safety. Good. Solid. Cool
B: Cool, cool. Neat neat- is this the alligator room? Yeah it is. I just make sure. M: Yeah you're good, you're good man
B: The exits probably in the corner right ( M: get that bandage.) I mean 20 Health's probably enough. I don't know
M: Okay. All right, man.. You do whatever you want man
B: I'm just gonna do this and that real quick
*All cheering*
W: Nice work!
B: Who's your fucking hero now? M:All right, okay. Hey wait, what! why
B: Well..
What!
Bob: Well fuck you Mark. I guess, have fun being dead you piece of garbage. M: But We had a system we trusted you- CANNON!
*Bob yelling* *explosion*
W: Hey Bob I don't have a shoe. Yeah. Yeah. I have two health we all have problems Wade
B: Nyoom, Oh that didn't uhh. OHO
B: I almost went in I almost went in there
M: Oh skull death. ohh That's such a weird one
*Wade grunting* B: What hurt me?
M: *Continuous Uh Oh's*
M: Bob no, bob NO, BOB NO
B: AHH NO! Wa- Wade listen
*Bob Oooo'ing Wade yelling* M: ohh god
B: OOoooookay
M: Wade? (B: There's shoes on the floor if you want them) Wade
M: Wade...  you're lagging (W: oh i'm fine)  Wade, oh god
B: Oh this is going well. M: Oh lag
B: This rooms not safe, you're gonna want to move right along here
W: Oh it's fine I'm just gonna.. B: You're gonna wanna move.. along
W: Oh this rooms gotta shoe and a thin- this rooms gonna be great
B: Oh hey!
M: If it's got a shoe it's definitely not deadly.
M: it's so warm in this room
It's so hot like I am burning alive.
B: Well, wade, I clutched it up on the last floor. So it's on you now man.
*yawning* It's so hot
M: It's just making me sleepy
M: It's so hot.
M: I think this is me slipping into the afterlife after my untimely demise.
Mark: Uggh
Wade: *quietly* Oh shoot, oh shoot
Bob: You get em' Wade you show- you show em' who's boss
Mark: You got it Wade
*Wade and bob screaming in fear*
Bob: ohh..
Wade: Why does it still hurt me?!
Mark and Bob: It's an explosion
Mark: Oh so it's so warm man. I
I think I'm in Hell, I think when I died. I-I think I think I went to hell. I'm so hot
B: I feel like, there's a really obvious- M:  I'm so hot. I'm so
*Sexy music*
*smooch* I'm so..
*Sexy Music*
Hawt..
W: Please be the exit. All right, I need that sweet big exit energy. M: I'll give you some big energy ;3. B: you're respawning mark
*Wade cheering* M: Wha- What wait hey I'm alive what whoah heyyy
W: Welcome back! M: Hiii
B: The corners have respawns in them? what the fuckk
M: No, no, I think it's just random, a random room might have a respawn. Hey buddy, how are you doing?
W: Oh, I'm feeling a hundred percent with two shoes. M: Wow. That's great, man
M: Yoinkus
M: Oh I'm so good, I'm so good. Watch this, Oh not today, oh not today
W: Oh there's creeper arms!
M: Yeah, whatever it's nothing. B: Oh flee Wade! Oh it almost got your ass Wade
M: *sigh* you gotta protect those asses man
W: Al- All the- all the asses are protections
M: Ohh that's no good. Alright well
W: Okay this room can't be that bad right
*Mark Uh Oh's* B: Mark not that way Mark! Mark Mark Mark
M: I'm fine... I'm fine
B: Oh okay I thought you acutally jumped over and I was like what the fuck
M: I... may have
W: A safe room? Oh with a shoe! Mark there's an extra shoe over here
M: I don't care get out of here (B: bandage over here too) you go away, man.
W: All right. M: I'm on my own
W: Okay, I guess. B:Wait Mark. Could you check the corner room for me?
M: Yeah I could do that for you. W: FOUND IT
All right
B: Yaayyy! M: I'm so hot *groan*
W: Double Res! Love gloves in the chat!
what ?B: love gloves? why do you have condoms emotes? W: they're not they're love gloves
M: That's what condom is- B: that's the name for condoms. W: No. No, it's a glove of love
W: It's not a condom
W: You can say it's a glove for love. M: Oh god. No, I thought that I thought it couldn't be this way. I
Thought it couldn't be this way?
B: Oh no! I wanted to do hello's, aww
B: He's dead M: No it was very much- B: How'd you die so fast?
M: It's just it was one of those rooms where I thought it couldn't get me like that
M: Anyway I'm dead. B: You can continue being hot now.
M: I'm soooo
Hot
* sexy jazz music continues*
I'm so warm
Oooooohhh
*groans and kissy noises*
I'm so
Warm I'm so warm
It's so hot in this room
Oh my
*bone cracking*
It's really hot I was so uncomfortable
Anyway, don't go in that don't trust it. Don't trust it by default
I was killed in a room that looked just like that. Do not trust it
B: I threw a shoe already. M: Oh, okay. You're good then go for it. B: My only last shoe
Who what do I care to die then?
W: Oh shit Oh shit Oh shit
*mark mocking while wade and bob struggle*
M: Oh wow that wasn't good, that wasn't good
W: O- Oh it hurts
*Splatter noise* M: Ohh
M: You had two heads. Well you guys oh wait I didn't even show it you guys died pathetically
M: Hey, I got a crate! B: Were you literally not even showing what was happening. M: I was on myself. I was focused on me
B: That's not good that's gross
M: What do I got? B: Am I gonna get a loot crate?
M: Oooooh I got pantsssss oooOOooOOh
B: Oh the visual what you did is even more concerning than the sound of what you did.
M: Sorry I'm distracted by the actual boob physics. Why are there boob physics? B: Oh my god. Why is that the boob physics they chose
M: I don't know. That's just weird. B:  that's concerning and I'm not gonna..
M: That's not that's not how boobs or physics works
*Marks outro music*
Thanks for watching! -Noah and all the other awesome translators